welcome back to the Mass Effect
Andromeda gameplay series in this video
we will take a look at profiles
favorites and your squad as you level up
at Mass Effect Andromeda you'll gain
access to dozens of skills and over 300
scale upgrades you're free to pick any
skill without being limited to a class
which allows you to create a pathfinder
that is totally suited to how you want
to play as we discovered last time there
are three main types of skills in the
game combat Ted and biotics as you
unlock skills over the course of the
game you'll also start gaining access to
profiles there are seven types let's
take a look at two of them the adept and
the Explorer the Adept profile is
perfect for players want to specialize
in biotics as you choose more biotic
skills the Adept profile will give you
bonuses to suit your play style and as
you can see choosing a depth gives
bonuses to duration and damage of your
biotics the more you invest in those
skills a higher level profiles you can
unlock or maybe you want to be more
versatile choosing some combat mixed
with biotic and tech skills this will
unlock the explorer profile giving you
perks and buffs that enhance all your
abilities and of course you can swap
these profiles at any time allow you to
keep the action fresh giving you a
number of ways to tackle every battle
and making sure you never feel locked
into a particular style of play this
brings us to favorites favorites are a
quick way to map three skills and a
single profile to one slot any time
during combat you can switch between one
of these four slots giving you access to
up to 12 of your favorite skills during
the course of a single fight here's an
example in this battle I've equipped a
favorites loadout designed for
long-range combat utilizing cloak a
sniper rifle to suppress oncoming
enemies the sniper alone isn't enough so
I'll deploy an assault tour it and toss
some grenades before switching to my
second-favorite slowed out it's designed
for close quarters combat loading these
new abilities puts them in a cool down
by default so I'll have to make do with
my shotgun until they're ready
the fiend is too powerful and I'm not in
any position to take it out immediately
but my new favorites are ready I'll make
my getaway using biotic charge and then
maneuver around this group of enemies
this favorites loadout is particularly
combo friendly so I'll engage by
comboing cryo beam and Lance for an
explosive result then clean up with my
shotgun it looks like the fiend is
taking an interest I'll do what I can
from a distance before switching to my
third-favorite slowed out one that
emphasizes range biotic abilities such
as backlash and shockwave as well as
flamethrower let's see if we can find a
better vantage point install the fiends
approach using backlash I can show
myself from oncoming fire and deflect it
back at the enemy this is particularly
useful against large crowds of enemies
however this horde is scattered so I'll
need to regroup looks like the fiend has
other plans I'll stand my ground by
using shockwave and then follow that up
a flamethrower
the fiend is hurt but it's going to take
more than that to defeat it switching to
my final favourites load out I'll engage
the fiend with soldier focused abilities
let's finish it off or flak cannon and
trip mines and when it comes to combat
don't forget your squad each of your six
squad mates has three active and to
passive skills in this case core uses
her biotics as a support character and
rack is a bruiser who can soak up lots
of damage not only can you set your
squad up around the battlefield ordering
them to defend locations attack targets
or rally to your side you can also team
up with them for devastating power
combos power combo is activate when you
or one of your squad mates Prime's an
enemy or groups of enemies setting them
up for the kill then your squad mate
jumps in to detonate and finish the job
and you can always level up your squad
mates to make them specifically good at
priming or detonating targets subscribe
to see the next instalment the gameplay
series for a look at exploration in Mass
Effect Andromeda
[Music]